what's your favorite
like or what is your biggest market you
think outside of home
new orleans new orleans i love you in
new orleans i love the louisiana
i wouldn't even say new orleans
louisiana new orleans baton rouge
lafayette new orleans is one of my
favorite cities i ever visited new
orleans is
is it i love them i think they put
voodoo on me
hey shout out to voodoo are you a
religious guy
yeah like for real yeah like
like what's your uh what's your religion
if you had to classify it are you like
christian
christian okay but
i ain't gonna get into that it's i want
i definitely want to study like
other i mean yeah cause i'm like i'm not
religious
so i'm not a big religion guy i'm very
uh i'm probably
i believe in god and i pray a lot
hey man like i pray so i probably i pray
you know how like
being muslim i think you gotta pray like
five times a day i wrote it seems like a
lot of work to be muslim shout out to
the muslims yeah i appreciate y'all's
dedication you do seem like it's a lot
like
pork and like and all that but like i
love the swimming i can honestly say
that like i probably
i probably prayed like five times and
like
i ain't gonna get into it i feel like i
don't know
go ahead man let it let it go what were
you gonna say
you feel like what i don't really know i
don't i don't know
much about christianity but i know i'm
christian
because that's what how i was raised so
i want to i want to dig more into
you know others i think it's possible
for you to believe in a god and not have
and not be religious because religion is
a uh
it's a very man-made thing
so you could be like you could be
spiritual you could believe in god
but i feel like each religion
is created by man and there's a lot of
things that there's a lot of holes in a
lot of religions you you should
definitely look into it
i'm gonna look into it but i gotta
classify myself as
you know christian because that's what
in case you're in case your your
family's watching
no no no no your grandma would be like
yo what the [ __ ]
i raised you better than that yeah
that's how i was raised so i you know
i mean i classified myself in this
kitchen hey that's dope
shout out to everybody out there you
know banging banging that god gang you
feel me